k
[Música]
Olá boa noite prazer falar com vocês
novamente Boa noite Alice bogel Isaac
Alexandre gauziski
por favor me deem uma posição se vocês
estão ouvindo bem o meu
áudio Como está o
áudio e vamos começar respondendo à
perguntas e eu queria discutir com vocês
os melhores artigos de nutrição do ano
de 2024 Então vamos tentar hoje
não tomar muito tempo com pergunta pra
gente ver esses artigos interessantes
que
compõem os melhores do ano passado
segundo uma avaliação do site examen.com
Estela Mares boa noite obrigado pelo
feedback Alice vog também confirmando
que o áudio tá legal então vamos lá
só um minutinho que eu tô usando browser
novo que tá dando uns boozin aqui
deveria
ter evitado de mudar né
eu tô usando aqui o Firefox ele não tá
querendo pessoal vai ter que sair e
entrar de novo tá aguardem um pouquinho
pronto entrei de novo Boa noite T Ana
Paula Boa noite
Uber Vamos tentar apresentar de novo
aqui
hum
pronto primeira pergunta é da Marilda
só um instantinho
o Dramin que é usado para enjoos
funciona bem no caso de enjoos por
altitude no
peru bem sim não é a principal condut
para quem tem problema com altitude mas
sim a inalação de óleos essenciais pode
ser uma estratégia complementar para
aliviar náuseas e dores de cabeça que tá
associado à altitude exagerada né
elevada no
peru então sintomas acontecem quando tem
hipóxia que baixa concentração de
oxigênio no ar e é comum em Cusco e
maup Então essa hipó essa baixa
circulação de oxigênio vai afetar
culação e equilíbrio corporal e os óleos
essenciais podem ajudar modulando alguns
receptores do sistema nervoso central
melhorando adaptação do organismo às
mudanças ambientais quais seriam esses
óleos essenciais óleo de hortelã
pimenta tem estudos preliminares que
mostram que tem propriedades analgésicas
e antieméticas né tira o náusea né
vontade de
vomitar o mentol que tem nesse óleo
estimula receptores de de frio na pele
mucosas isso vai reduzir a percepção de
dor e náusea tem também o gengibre o
essencial de gengibre tem gingerol que é
um composto com ação comprovada contra
enjos você pode usar uma gota diluída em
água para inalação ou aplicação no pulso
e o óleo essencial de eucalipto que
descongestiona as vias respiratórias
facilitando a oxigenação e o óleo de
lavanda tem efeito calmante que reduz o
stresse fis lógico causado pela altitude
Então são esses olhos hortel
Pimenta gengibre eucalipto E lavanda
então você pode sempre utilizar duas a
três gotas do óleo essencial em um lenço
ou difusor portátil inalando
profundamente a cada duas ou 3 horas é
importante usar um produto de boa
qualidade
puro e testar antes em uma área pequena
da pele para ver se você não tem reação
alérgica caso você não tenha utilizado
antes e combinar essa abordagem com a
hidratação intensa especialmente água
com
eletrólitos alimentação leve rica em
magnésio é o caso por exemplo de abacate
banana o descanso adequado também
potencializa os
resultados agora em termos de
medicamento O que é mais recomendado é o
inibidor da anidrase carbônica acet
zolamid acetazolamida que é
a causa da da da segunda
pergunta que é o uso de medicamentos a
base de acetos
alamina desculpa acetos
lamida utilizado para prevenir hipóxia
seria indicado para uso em altitude sim
é
indicado tá
Ah desculpa pulei uma pergunta aqui tem
a pergunta do
dramim vamos lá a pergunta do dramim
primeiro depois a gente fala da
acetazolamida Então o dramim que é usado
para enjoos funciona bem no caso de
enjoos por altitude no peru não é bem
indicado nisso aí tá o dramim ele é um
antistamínico que é utilizado como
agente antiemético né contra vômitos
especialmente vômitos e náuseas ligadas
a movimento né A
cetose mas não é a primeira opção para
enjoos por altitude a doença da altitude
ela ocorre devido a baixa oxigenação a
baixa pressão de
oxigênio leva a náuseas dor de cabeça e
fadiga mas o tratamento principal é a
acetazolamida que
é a a próxima pergunta é o medicamento
que é utilizado para várias condições né
é um antihipertensivo usado para
glaucoma também e esse mamento vai
ajudar a adaptar o corpo a altitude
também hidratação adequada repouso
evitar álcool tudo isso vai
ajudar além dos óleos essenciais que eu
comentei você pode usar o óleo essencial
de gengibre ou o próprio o próprio
gengibre em chá ou gengibre ralado você
pode usar cúrcuma
chá de camomila e lavanda também pode
ajudar e o dramim pode até aliviar a
náusea mas não é específico né ele tem
um problema também de ter um efeito
sedativo porque ele é um antistamínico
isso em altitudes elevadas pode deixar
você
tonto junto com a questão da Baixa
oxigenação Então não é tão interessante
usar o Dramin não tá a próxima pergunta
uso de medicamentos a base de acetos
lamida utilizado para prevenir hipóxia
seria indicado para uso e altitude sim a
resposta é sim tá É sim indicado para
prevenção e tratamento de síncope da
montanha doença da altitude que vai
reduzir dor de cabeça análise fadiga ele
funciona como diurético porque ele inibe
a anidrase carbônica e ajuda adaptar o
corpo abaixa a pressão de oxigênio e
altitudes altas ele tem que ser iniciado
24 horas antes da Ascensão né da subida
a montanha e mantido por 48 horas após
atingir a altitude Mas ele tem efeitos
colaterais como boca seca fadiga e
sensação de formigamento e já falamos
das alternativas né de óleos essenciais
além do chá de camomila gengibre também
podemos falar do chá de boldo que também
pode
ajudar e quais são os sintomas que a
acetos salamida causa ou ataca aqui na
pergunta como ela
colocou como ele é um inibidor da
anidrase carbônica ele é utilizado
princialmente no
glaucoma mas também no mal da montanha o
efeito dele se concentra em reduzir a
pressão intraocular quando a pessoa tem
glaucoma aliviar sintomas como dor de
cabeça e fadiga no mal da montanha e
auxiliar no controlle de crises
epilépticas em alguns casos
né Já falamos aqui dos efeitos
colaterais mas eu quis falar um pouco
também dos efeitos
eh dessa medicação para outras doenças
próxima pergunta exame de pesquisa de
sangue oculto n Fes positiva é
preocupante depende
né Que que isso indica indica que tem
sangue não visível a olho nu nas feses
isso Geralmente vem de
microso do trato digestório Então tem
que ficar de olho não é imediatamente
ante Mas merece uma investigação para
identificar a causa que pode variar de
condições benignas como fissura anal
hemorroida e até umas úlceras
pequenas até problemas mais graves como
inflamação intestinal pólipo até câncer
de intestino
grosso Então esse exame não é específico
ele é um exame de triagem que tem valor
especialmente pessoas acima de 50 anos
que tem risco maior de câncer intestino
grosso
quando acontece desse exame tá positivo
e não tem uma causa imediata uma causa
óbvia para esse sangue oculto nas feses
tá indicado fazer endoscopia digestiva
alta e
colonoscopia Ok para descartar o
pior e entrar com uma abordagem
integrativa com dieta antiinflamatória
aumento de água e fibras na alimentação
uso de probióticos chá
digestivos já falamos aqui da camomila
do boldo do gengibre né pro contexto da
doença de altitude mas também cabem aqui
né e evitar agentes irritantes como
álcool alimentos picantes
antiinflamatórios não esteroidais e
excesso de
cafeína E lembrando que existe os falsos
positivos alguns alimentos como
beterraba tomate e pimentão pode causar
falsos positivo se a pessoa tiver
tomando aspirina ou as para prevenção
pode também causar o micross gramento
e d falso
positivo Então tem que ficar atento a
essas questões
aí ah próxima
pergunta como abordar o climatério em
mulheres com
Burnout então tem algumas estratégias
para aliviar sintomas hormonais reduzir
o stresse crônico você pode usar chá
calmantes como camomila lavanda e
Valeriana que vão ajudar a equilibrar o
sistema nervoso central reduzindo a
ansiedade Insônia o gengibre e a culcuma
São antiinflamatórios pode aliviar dores
musculares e melhorar a circulação tem
alguns suplementos de climatério que eu
acho muito interessantes que é o caso da
do vitex agnos
castos e também do licorice e também do
Black cor roch que é o cimicifuga
racemosa E tem também a nigra né todos
esses aí são interessantes para regular
os hormônios no
climatério alimentação importante tem
que ser rico em ômega-3 magnésio
vitamina D adequada né então os
alimentos seriam né os peixes gordurosos
de mar né que não tenham Mercúrio Folhas
Verdes e
amendoins e a exposição solar em relação
à vitamina D soja é um pouco polêmico né
soja fermentada acho uma boa soja não
fermentada eu não recomendo tá semente
de linhaça tem fitoestrógenos que pode
ajudar yoga meditação ajuda demais né
caminhadas ao ar livre contato com a
natureza hidratação Alimentação adequada
evitar álcool e
cafeína e também uso jinzen coriano pode
ajudar uso de probióticos também pode
ajudar tá então falei várias opções aqui
que vocês podem estar revendo depois
eh esse suplemento flor assist Life
extension os bacteriófagos são
suplementos fantásticos resolveram o meu
problema de disbiose em apenas cinco
cápsulas diárias cinco cápsulas
diárias bastante né mas que bom que
resolveu agora com feses bem formadas e
consistentes voltamos à
metilação eu já faço uma dieta pobre Ina
tenho vários polimorfismos envolvidos
nessas enzimas eu também tenho
dificuldades também em formar metionina
os polimorfismos MTR mtrr e
ahc são extremamente difíceis ajustar a
dieta com suplementação se eu não
tivesse esse polimorfismo a minha
homocisteina seria bem mais alta
suplementação com Sam e metionina são
contraindicados para mim e o meu ajuste
fino para deixar um em números ideais
será quantificando a suplementação do
nac dosando sempre no sangue a
homocisteína para ficar na casa dos oito
e meu Gama GT abaixo de 20 ou qual
outros nutraceuticos para fazer essa
regulação então eh a gente pode est
abordando de várias formas isso já falou
do nac NS cisteína É uma opção a
glutationa que é uma das vias de saída
da homocisteína
vai ajudar também no tox do fígado vai
ajudar a reduzir a homocisteína a dose
Inicial é de 600 a 900 MG por dia em
casos assim que você
esteja doente você pode aumentar a dose
para até uns 1800 MG por dia mas vamos
colocar aqui essa dose média de 600 a
900 MG ao
dia a betaína nidra também conhecida
como trimetilglicina é doador de de
grupo metil é uma boa para você dose que
pode ser de 500 mg a 1 g por dia manter
a B12 níveis adequados eh metilfolato ou
adenosil metilfolato não desculpa metil
cobalamina ou adenosil cobalamina que as
dos pode ser entre 500 a 1000 microg ao
dia e no caso do folato n mi folato de
400 a 800 microg por dia a o perido xal
cin fosfato ajuda na conversão de
homocisteina enc staa você pode usar de
20 a 50 mg por dia a colina ajuda a
baixar homocisteína e também dá suporte
à síntese de fosfolipídeos o inositol
também
ajuda nessa dose que você pode estar
utilizando de 500 mg a 1 g por dia de
Colina e 500 mg por dia de inositol e
Como monitorar o próprio mista que você
comentou se você tiver a ácido
metilmalônico que é um marcador de
estresse oxidativo é interessante e
também medir a cistationina que é um dos
derivados aí do ciclo da metilação tá se
puder medir isso aí é interessante você
mede a cada se meses isso vai ajudar a
ajustar as
doses e também manter o monitoramento do
Gama GT e da função hepática
ok mant pobre metionina prioriza
alimentos ricos em folato e betaína Ok
quais são os alimentos ricos em folato
Folhas Verdes legumes e betaína é ovos e
abacate
evite toxinas ambientais mantém hábitos
saudáveis de sono exercício
moderado próxima pergunta do Isaac
Lima Por quanto tempo se pode utilizar
os fitoterápicos como bacopa bonieri
Biloba Resveratrol jinzen indiano chuba
de leão qual o período de descanso olha
geralmente o que se fala aí nos livros
textos nos blogs nos artigos é que você
utilize 3 meses em média e pode fazer um
período de descanso de um mês
tá esse é o período mais comum mas
alguns fitoterápicos são seguros de usar
por se meses seguidos
Ok J de leão o que eu já L é que pode
ser utilizado continuamente não precisa
fazer o
intervalo
ã próxima pergunta J de leão pode ser
usado por hipertenso ela interage com
gin cobiloba
não é contra dicado para hipertenso
hipertenso pode usar o juba de
leão o uso com Jic cobiloba em alguns
casos pode aumentar o risco de
sangramento então se você tiver usando
algum anticoagulante ou antiagregante é
bom não utilizar esse anticoagulante ou
não usar a combinação de juba de leão
e Gin cobiloba
OK outra coisa que o gcob lobo pode
interagir com alguns medicamentos
antihipertensivos como é o caso dos
inibidores de eca né da enzima
conversora de angiotensina que é o caso
eh das de boa parte das medicações
hipertensivas e também dos
betabloqueadores
ah próxima pergunta na sua opinião juba
de leão e piracetan Teria algum
benefício da adh juba de leão já usei
muito para Alzheimer ele é um ativo
interessante ele estimula gênes melhora
a função
cognitiva não me lembro de ter lido
sobre ele no contexto do
TDH mas ele pode regular a tensão né no
TDH mas não foi tão estudado para isso
né piracetan é o not trópico aumenta a
concentração em
memória mas não tem assim estudos
conclusivos sobre a eficácia combinada
desses dois no
TDH você pode começar com eles
individualmente isoladamente depois
juntar e ver como é que você responde a
isso
certo tem mais uma pergunta aqui do
Eliseu deixa eu aumentar o tamanho da
letra
aqui uma pessoa feriu a perna num
acidente doméstico como ela demorou para
ir ao hospital público por ISS o
hospital público orientou a pessoa
voltar ao hospital para tocar um
curativo todos os dias durante dois
meses dois meses até a ferida
fechar acontece que a cada dia usa uma
pomada diferente o pessal disse a pessoa
que não faz mal usar pomada
diferente suspeito de terem mentido para
ela dizendo que não precisa ser a mesma
pomada todo dia Não não precisa ser uma
mesma pomada não tem que ser uma pomada
que promova a cicatrização
né
certo o Eliseu tá dizendo aqui que o som
tá saindo baixo alguém confirma
isso que o som tá saindo
baixo eu vou aumentar um pouquinho o
volume aqui se ficar muito alto vocês me
falam tá
porque a informação que eu tava tendo é
que tava Ok o
áudio não tem problema dizer eu de
simplesmente trocar essa pomada todo dia
tá contanto que sejam pomadas
equivalentes que promovam a cicatrização
tá Alice vog tá dizendo que o som tá bom
Denise tá dizendo que tá picotando
Denise aí é o caso é internet tá e você
tá picotando não é pro de equipamento
não é problema de
internet
certo D diendo que mandou
pergunta
Ah tá mas eu já respondi acho que a
pergunta que tá como Ana
aqui gente eu prefiro não responder
muita pergunta não tá vamos até
as no máximo até 7:40 com pergunta tá
paraa gente poder falar dos artigos
não é recomendado fazer muito esforço
físico depois de uma de uma refeição
volumosa porque realmente sim a
circulação esplâncnica aumenta o sangue
fica concentrado na circulação
esplâncnica e pode faltar sangue pros
membros pros músculos Tá bom pode
acontecer um problema sim mas isso
acontece com digestões de alimentações
muito grandes né PR comu bastante tá bom
alguns probióticos sim precisam de
geladeira outros não elizu depende
tá não você tem que tomar primeiro
antibiótico e depois o probiótico tomar
junto não é uma boa ideia não a não ser
que seja um antibiótico natural aí é
aceitável você tomar um antibiótico
natural de manhã e tomar o probiótico à
noite aqui uma informação que o som tá
bom não soro sim é adequado usar o soro
para lavar a ferida e depois usar uma
pomada cicatrizante antisséptica tá
seria essa a sequência
elizu
tá obrigado Stela bem vamos ao
artigo aliás artigo não são vários
artigos né são 10 artigos que eu queria
falar com vocês aqui são os top tem top
10 estudos científicos
2024 Bem pessoal vamos lá Imagine que
você tá na academia preparando a
refeição PRS treino e alguém te diz que
você está desperdiçando
proteína por quê Por décadas Esse é um
tema de debate intenso na comunidade de
Fit nesse fisiculturismo existia essa
crença baseada em alguns estudos de que
o nosso corpo tinha uma capacidade
limitada de absorção proteica que era
algo de 20 a 30 G por refeição então
qualquer quantidade que subisse além
disso supostamente seria jogado fora
mais um estudo de
2024 bem desenhado desafiou
completamente a essa
crença teve um experimento
meticulosamente controlado e randomizado
que os pesquisadores dividiram os
participantes em dois grupos um grupo
consumiu 25 g de proteína quantidade
tradicionalmente recomendada que
inclusive vocês vão ver lá nos V Protein
da vida geralmente é essa quantidade que
tem lá no Scoop Enquanto o outro grupo
consumiu 100 g bem mais né cinco vezes
mais praticamente desculpa quatro vezes
mais então utilizando técnicas avançadas
de marcação isotópica eles rastrearam o
destino dos aminoácidos do
corpo Então os cientistas Conseguiram
fazer uma descoberta surpreendente o
grupo que consumiu 100 g apresentou uma
taxa significativamente maior de síntese
proteica tanto muscular quanto em todo o
corpo Então realmente aproveitou aqueles
100 g não foi jogado fora
então o que que significa isso na
prática né imagine o seu corpo como uma
construção os aminoá são os tijolos e a
síntese proteica é o processo de
construção então o estudo mostrou que
seu corpo é como um canteiro de obras
muito mais eficiente do que se pensava é
capaz de utilizar muito mais material de
construção de uma só vez então para
atletas pessoas que fazem apenas uma ou
duas refeições por dia ou aqueles que
seguem jejum intermitente essa
descoberta é
relevante Então não precisa mais dividir
a proteína em várias pequenas porções ao
longo do dia como era recomendado para
maximizar ganhos você pode continuar
ganhando massa muscular fazendo
refeições maiores com mais proteínas
menos vezes ao
dia então quando a gente entra no
território do velhecimento Saudável essa
descobertas ficam ainda mais relevantes
uma meta análise abrangente que combinou
dados de diversos estudos com idosos
trouxe à tona uma sinergia poderosa
entre treino resistido e suplementação
proteica Então pense nisso como uma
orquestra então o exercício é o maestro
E a proteína são os músicos juntos eles
criam uma sinfonia de benefícios Então
os pesquisadores mediram vários aspectos
da função física mas um indicador se
destacou de maneira particular que é a
velocidade de caminhada Então por que
que isso importante a velocidade com que
uma pessoa caminha é considerado um dos
melhores preditores de longevidade e
qualidade de vida na terceira idade
então termômetro de saúde geral Então os
participantes que combinaram treino
resistido que é de força com
suplementação
proteica não apenas mantiveram a
velocidade de caminhada como também
melhoraram essa velocidade de forma
significativa o estudo também revelou
algo intrigante sobre o tipo de proteína
utilizada foram diferentes Fontes que
foram testadas O eprin que é o soro do
leite
caseína que é a parte que vira queijo né
podemos dizer assim a proteína da soja e
mistura de fontes e curiosamente todos
apresentaram benefícios mais as
proteínas de absorção mais lenta nesse
estudo vejam que eu falo mal da caseína
por ser inflamatório mas nesse estudo
eles falam bem da
caseína porque aparentemente essa
proteína de absorção mais lenta tem uma
leve vantagem quando consumido antes de
dormir é muito fisiculturista faz isso
eles consomem a casina antes de dormir
para não perder músculo durante durante
a noite então esse estudo tá dando né
uma colher de chá aí paraa casina
Dizendo que ela funciona bem
né durante o sono então Eli ele diz que
essa proteína é melhor que as outras E
por falar em treino resistido na
terceira idade teve um outro estudo que
trouxe resultados que mudaram paradigm
sobre intensidade de treino para idosos
durante muito tempo existia um certo
receio em prescrever treinos pesados
para idosos muitos profissionais com
medo de lesões acabavam recomendando
apenas exercícios leves ou moderados Mas
será que eles estavam sendo super
protetores Então esse segundo estudo
acompanhou três grupos de idosos por um
período inicial de 1 ano o primeiro
grupo realizou treinos resistidos
pesados com cargas entre 80 a 85% da
força máxima que é basicamente o o tipo
de treino que eu faço o segundo grupo
fez treinos moderados com 60 a 65% de
carga máxima e o terceiro grupo ser como
controle não realizando treinos
sistematizados mas o mais impressionante
não foi o que aconteceu durante o ano de
treino foi o que aconteceu depois do ano
de treino então nos três anos seguintes
que não treinaram então eles treinaram
durante o ano e nos TRS anos seguintes
eles não
treinaram então os pesquisadores
continuaram monitorando esses idosos que
pararam de treinar e os resultados foram
surpreendentes aqueles que haviam
participado do grupo de treino PES AD
mantiveram níveis significativamente
maiores de força e massa muscular mesmo
anos após o término do programa original
é como se o treino pesado tivesse criado
uma espécie de reserva física que
continua beneficiando essas pessoas por
anos mas os benefícios Não Param por aí
o grupo de treino pesado também
apresentou melhores resultados em testes
de Equilíbrio menor risco de quedas e
surpreendentemente melhor função com
cognitiva Olha só gente melhor função
cognitiva Então essa história de
marombeiro é burro né só se for
marombeiro que se top de anabolizante né
porque não o
marombeiro que é Fitness que não faz
besteira ele tem uma melhor função
cognitiva
ISO sugere que o impacto do treino
resistido vai muito além dos músculos
ele afeta o corpo lembra da irisina que
eu falei em vídeo de anos atrás que que
é o hormônio que foi descoberto há uns
12 anos atrás e que pode afetar de forma
positiva o cérebro então malhar ajuda o
cérebro certo melhora a função
cognitiva então mudando um pouco o foco
paraa nutrição Então vamos falar do
terceiro estudo aqui Uma pesquisa
prospectiva realizada na Itália trouxe
novos insights sobre o ingrediente
milenar da dieta mediterrânea que é o
azeite de oliva que vocês estão cansados
de saber que é ótimo né este não foi
apenas um estudo a mais sobre dieta foi
uma investigação profunda que acompanhou
milhares de pessoas por mais de uma
década analisando não apenas quanto
azeite elas consumiam mas também como
isso impactava a saúde a longo prazo
Então os pesquisadores dividiram os
participantes em diferentes grupos
baseados no consumo de azit de oliva e
eles não ser limitaram a perguntar
quanto azeite foi consumido eles
analisaram também detalhadamente o tipo
de azeite como é que ele era usado se
era azeite cru ou cozido né usado no
cozimento e até mesmo a qualidade desse
azeite então o grupo com maior consumo
de azeite de oliva extravirgem
apresentou uma redução impressionante de
20% no risco de mortalidade por todas as
causas 25% menos mortes por doenças
cardiovasculares e uma redução de 15 da
mortalidade por
câncer mas o que que torna o azeite de
oliva tão especial já falamos sobre isso
mas vamos rever isso daí tem vários
mecanismos primeiro tem os
polifenóis que são compostos
antioxidantes potentes que combatem a
inflamação crônica temos os ácidos gros
monoinsaturados que ajudam a manter a
saúde cardiovascular
e tem uma descoberta interessante de que
o azeite parece interagir de forma
positiva com o microbioma intestinal
isso eu também não sabia promovendo uma
flora bacteriana mais
saudável e como era se de esperar os
benefícios são doses dependentes quanto
mais azeite de oliva você consumir
dentro de limites razoáveis né ninguém
vai tomar 3 l de azeite por dia maiores
eram os
benefícios o grupo que mais se
beneficiou consumia cerca de quatro a
cinco colheres de sopa por dia
principalmente na forma de extra virgem
e consumido cru pessoal é importante
lembrar que No Brasil existe muito muito
muito azeite adulterado você tem que ter
muito cuidado não compra azeite em
lata leia os rótulos não compre azeite
que não seja extra
virgem a marca somente não é suficiente
tem marcas aí muito famosas que tem
produtos ruins porque eles têm uma faixa
de produtos tem uma linha de produtos
que alguns são péssimos e outros são
ótimos então geralmente eles fazem isso
para aumentar penetração de mercado mas
não façam o uso de azeite sem ler
extensivamente o rótulo
tá vamos pro próximo assunto próximo
estudo então azeite de oliva extravirgem
excelente tá tentem consumir o máximo
que puder apesar que aumentou multipreço
recentemente Então o próximo estudo é
para aqueles que lutam contra o sono
ruim
né uma metanálise recente e abrangente
sobre melatonina trouxe informações
práticas e
precisas não foi só amenas não foi
somente mais uma revisão sobre os
benefícios da melatonina foi uma análise
matemática sofisticada que conseguiu
identificar exatamente como maximizar os
benefícios desse suplemento Então os
pesquisadores analisaram mais de 50
estudos diferentes a metanálise
incluindo mais de 5.000 participantes
usando técnicas estatísticas avançadas
eles conseguiram criar um modelo que
previa exatamente como diferentes doses
e horários de consumo afetavam o sono
então a descoberta mais surpreendente é
que a dose ideal ficou entre 3 e 4 mg Eu
já vi até em palestra médica
alguns pesquisadores e professores
falando que essa dose era alta pra
mulher especialmente Mas eu sempre achei
que essa dose não era tão alta
assim então dose ideal entre 3 e 4 mg
muito menor do que as doses de 10 ou
mais miligram de alguns
suplementos mas tem que ver que tem
algumas pessoas que TM alteração
genética e ficam ressaque no dia
seguinte se tomam melat
Então esse tipo de gente ou toma
melatonina mais cedo ainda no início da
noite ou toma melatonina de liberação
lenta né ou até evita esse suplemento
tem pessoas que são muito sensíveis
melatonina
mesmo então teve uma descoberta
interessante sobre o timing o estudo
mostrou que tomar melatonina 3 horas
antes de dormir era melhor era mais
efetivo do que tomar logo antes de
deitar eu tava recomendando Até
recentemente tomar uma hora antes uma
hora antes mas esse estudo tá sugerindo
que 3 horas antes é melhor E por quê
Porque a melatonina não é Tecnicamente
um sonífero isso já sabia ela é um
sincronizador circadiano e tomá-la muito
próximo do horário de
dormir É como tentar acertar o relógio
quando já está na hora do alarme tocar
então el L vai agir melhor 3 horas antes
de deitar Tá
bom eu e o estudo também identificou
diferentes perfis de resposta melatonina
pessoas com mais de 55 anos tendem a
responder melhor a dose ligeiramente
maiores próximas a 4 mg e adultos jovens
T resultados interessantes com 3
MG e também foi descoberto que a
eficácia da melatonina aumentava de
forma significativa quando combinada com
boas práticas de higiene do Sono como
era esperado que é o caso de você
desligar as luzes Du horas antes de
dormir manter o quarto escuro evitar
telas azuis aquela história toda né
então quando o assunto é nutrição
esportiva vamos falar de um outro estudo
agora tem um que fala sobre o timing do
consumo de
carboidratos e esse estudo trouxe
descobertas cruciais para atletas e
praticantes de exercício intenso os
pesquisadores investigaram como o
momento do consumo de carboidratos após
do treino afetava o desempenho do dia
seguinte e os resultados
surpreenderam Então esse estudo utilizou
um desenho crossover onde os mesmos
atletas testaram diferentes Protocolos
de consumo de carboidratos esse tipo de
estudo tá muito em vogga ultimamente
porque é bem interessante porque você
pega o mesmo indivíduo e submete ele a
regimes diferentes e compara os
resultados de regimes diferentes então
em uma condição essas pessoas consum um
carboidratos imediatamente após o treino
em outra condição a mesma pessoa
esperava 3 horas para consumir o
carboidrato a quantidade total de
carboidratos era sempre a mesma só o
timing que mudava Então os pesquisadores
não só mediram o desempenho físico mas
também analisaram marcadores bioquímicos
como glicogênio muscular resposta
hormonal e marcador de recuperação
muscular e os resultados mostraram que
adiaram o consumo de carboidratos por 3
horas resultou em uma queda de 15% no
desempenho exercício de alta intensidade
no dia seguinte então análises mais
profundas revelaram que o grupo que
consumiu carboidratos imediatamente após
o treino teve melhor resultado então
apresentou uma reposição de glicogênio
muscular 25% maior nas primeiras 4 horas
após o treino após o
exercício mas talvez a descoberta mais
interessante tenha sido sobre o tipo de
carboidrato o estudo testou diferentes
fatores diferentes Fontes desde açúcares
simples Até carbohidratos complexos e
descobriu que uma combinação de glicose
e frutose na proporção de dois para um
era mais efetiva que qualquer outra
fonte
isolada isso porque diferentes tipos de
carboidratos utilizavam diferentes trans
portadores no intestino permitindo uma
absorção mais rápida e
eficiente Pessoal lembrando que nós
estamos falando aqui de atletas não é
pessoa com resist insulínica não é
pré-diabético aí tomar muito cuidado
pessoas que estão nessa condição aí ou
tão obesas não devem utilizar
carboidratos simples Ok bem continuando
aqui a questão da janela anabólica que é
um tipo
que tem sido um dos Tópicos mais
debatidos na nutrição
esportiva é o próximo assunto que nós
vamos discutir
aqui por anos os atletas corriam para
consumir proteína imediatamente após o
treino temendo perder os ganhos se não
fizessem dentro dessa janela de 30 a 60
minutos então tem um novo estudo com
homens treinados que trouxe uma
perspectiva Libertadora sobre esse tema
Então os pesquisadores recrutaram 50
homens com pelo menos 3 anos de
experiência em treino resistido de força
e todos seguiam uma dieta rica em
proteína 2 g por kg dia de peso
corporal e foram divididos em diferentes
grupos baseados no timing do consumo
proteico um grupo consumia proteína
imediatamente após o treino outro
esperava duas horas e o terceiro grupo
consumi A proteína de forma aleatória ao
longo do dia então após 12 semanas de
treino controlado as medidas de força
hipertrofia hipertrofia e composição
corporal foram surpreendentemente
similares entre os grupos Então não teve
essa história de janela anabólica
análise biópsia muscular mostrou que a
síntese proteica muscular permanecia
levada por mais
tempo aliás permanecia levada por muito
mais tempo do que se acreditava
anteriormente até 24 a 48 horas após o
treino Então essa janela
metabólica essa janela de hipertrofia é
muito mais longa do que você imaginava
não são de minutos são de muitas horas
né de 24 a 48 horas após o treino o
estudo também investigou diferentes
marcadores moleculares de crescimento
muscular incluindo o famoso
emitor e outras duas moléculas
p70
s6k e 4 e bp1 então curiosamente esses
marcadores permaneciam elevados por
períodos muito mais longos do que a
tradicional janela
anabólica isso indica que nosso
corpo é muito mais adaptativo e flexível
do que era
pensado então uma análise
extraordinariamente detalhada sobre o
consumo de carne vermelha aí já outro
estudo tá pessoal vamos lá uma análise
extraordinariamente detalhada sobre o
consumo de carne vermelha e mortalidade
trouxe uma nova perspectiva sobre como
interpretamos dados epidemiológicos este
não foi apenas mais um estudo de sobre
carne vermelha foi uma
masterclass na metodologia científica
Então os pesquisadores pegaram o
conjunto de dados sobre consumo de carne
vermelha e mortalidade e analisaram de
mais de 1000 maneiras diferentes 1000
maneiras diferentes eles variaram os
métodos
estatísticos as variáveis de controle os
critérios de exclusão e até mesmo as
definições de alto e baixo consumo o
objetivo não era necessariamente
descobrir se a carne vermelha era boa ou
ruim mas entender como diferentes
escolhas metodológicas podem afetar as
conclusões de um estudo em mais de 80%
das análises não foi encontrado nenhuma
Associação significativa entre consumo
de carne vermelha e mortalidade geral e
mais de 80% das análises a carne
vermelha não estava associado a aumento
de mortalidade Ok mas o mais
interessantes foram as análises onde
encontraram associações positivas ou
negativas ao examinar essas análises
mais de perto os pesquisadores
identificaram padrões interessantes
sobre como diferentes escolhas
metodológicas poderiam empurrar os
resultados em diferentes
direções o estudo também fez uma análise
fascinante sobre viés de publicação e
como as conclus dos estudos podem ser
influenciados por fatores não
relacionados aos dados eles descobriram
que estudos que encontravam associações
negativas entre o consumo de carne
vermelha e saúde tinham uma
probabilidade significativamente maior
de serem publicados em revistas de alto
impacto Olha
só uma metanálise em rede sobre fontes
proteicas e ganho muscular trouxe
insights valiosos sobre como diferentes
proteínas afeta o crescimento
muscular esse tipo de análise é
particularmente poderoso porque permite
comparar diferentes intervenções mesmo
quando elas nunca foram testadas
diretamente uma contra a
outra os pesquisadores analisaram dados
de mais de 100 estudos incluindo mais de
2000 participantes eles não só
compararam diferentes fontes de
proteínas que era Láctea carne ovos
proteínas
Vegetais mas também diferentes de
consumo diferentes perfis de aminoácidos
Então os resultados mostraram que
proteínas de origem animal especialmente
lácteos e carnes tendiam a produzir
ganhos ligeiramente maiores em massa
muscular e
força no entanto a diferença não era tão
grande quanto se pensava anteriormente
mais interessante ainda foi a descoberta
de que a combinação de diferentes Fontes
proteicas frequentemente superavam
Fontes isoladas Isso aqui é uma coisa
interessante porque eu particularmente
utilizo
eh a proten junto com
colágeno Então já fazia isso já sem
saber desse estudo
né então A análise do perfil de
aminoácido revelou que o conteúdo de
leucina era o preditor mais forte de
ganhos muscular seguido pela lisina e a
metionina isso explica porque que
algumas Fontes vegetais quando
adequadamente combinadas podem produzir
resultados similares às Fontes
animais por fim uma descoberta
verdadeiramente surpreendente veio de um
estudo sobre alongamento e hipertrofia
eu achei esse estudo bem interessante
por décadas o alongamento foi visto
principalmente como uma forma de
melhorar a flexibilidade nunca se pensou
que a long poderia dar hipertrofia né só
de melhorar a flexibilidade e prevenir
lesão Então nesse estudo de 8
semanas esse conceito foi desafiado os
pesquisadores dividiram 30 participantes
em três grupos um grupo fez apenas
alongamento estático intenso outro
realizou treino resistido tradicional e
um terceiro grupo Serviu de
controle o protocolo de alongamento não
era nada parecido com que a maioria das
As pessoas faz na academia cada
alongamento era mantido por até 5
minutos isso uma eternidade né em termos
de alongamento e com uma intensidade
progressivamente aumentada verdadeira
sessão de tortura chegando a nível de
desconforto significativo Então os
resultados após oit semanas deixaram a
comunidade científica perplexa o grupo
de alongamento intenso apresentou ganho
de massa muscular Eu nunca imaginei isso
aí e também ganho de força comparável ao
grupo que fez treino resistido
tradicional as biópsias musculares
revelaram que o alongamento intenso
ativava muitas das mesmas vias
moleculares que associadas à hipertrofia
como mitor
né A análise microscópica dos tdos
musculares mostrou algo fascinante o
alongamento intenso causava microlesões
igual a própria musculação microlesões
musculares de maneira similar ao treino
resistido mas através de um mecanismo
diferente enquanto o treino resistido
causa dano principalmente através da
contração concêntrica e excêntrica o
alongamento causava tensão mecânica
através de estiramento prolongado Então
os pesquisadores mediram diversos
marcadores inflamatórios e fatores de
crescimento no sangue surpreendentemente
o grupo de alongamento mostrou aumentos
similares de gf1 que é o insulin Grow
Vector um né o fator de crescimento
parecido com a insulina que é derivado
do hormônio crescimento e também do
emitor que são dois importantes
sinalizadores de crescimento
muscular a expressão gênica relacionada
a c proteica também foi similarmente
elevado Em ambos os grupos no entanto é
importante vocês saberem que o protocolo
de alongamento foi descrito pelos
participantes como muito muito
desafiador extremamente desafiador
muitos relataram níveis de desconforto
que beiravam a dor especialmente nas
primeiras semanas a adesão ao programa
foi menor no grupo de alongamento com
alguns participantes T dificuldade de
manter a intensidade
prescrita o estudo também incluiu um
segmento de quatro semanas após o
término do programa principal e de forma
interessante o grupo de alongamento
Manteve mais dos seus ganhos durante
esse
período Possivelmente devido à
adaptações nas propriedades mecânicas do
tecido muscular que persistiram mesmo
após o fim de Treinamento Então essa
descoberta abre possibilidades
empolgantes para pessoas que não podem
realizar treino resistido por algum
motivo o treino de musculação
tradicional devido a limitações de
equipamento ou condições médicas no
entanto os pesquisadores enfatizam o que
mais estudos são necessários para
determinar a segurança e eficácia desse
protocolo em diferentes populações
especialmente em dosos ou pessoas que
têm condições músculoesqueléticas
preexistentes
o estudo também investigou os mecanismos
celulares e moleculares por trás desses
ganhos surpreendentes análise detalhadas
revelaram aumentos Na expressão de genes
relacionados à mecanotransdução que é o
processo pelo qual as células musculares
convertem estímulos mecânicos em sinais
bioquímicos isso sugere que o
alongamento intenso pode ativar vias de
crescimento muscular através de
mecanismos únicos diferentes daqueles
tradicionalmente associados ao treino
resistido Então as implicações desse
estudo vão além do crescimento muscular
os pesquisadores observaram melhorias
significativas na
flexibilidade obviamente né porque
alongamento aumenta a flexibilidade mas
também na função neuromuscular e no
controle motor participantes relataram
melhor consci corporal redução de dores
crônicas e até mesmo melhor qualidade de
sono embora estes não fossem os
objetivos principais de
estudo então para o futuro os
pesquisadores planejam investigar como
esse protocolo de alongamento intenso
poderia ser modificado para diferentes
populações incluindo atletas idosos e
pessoas em estado de
reabilitação eles também Estão
interessados em entender como diferentes
variáveis como duração do
alongamento sequên das sessões de
intensidade podem ser otimizadas para
maximizar os benefícios enquanto
minimiza o
desconforto Então esse estudo não apenas
desafia a compreensão tradicional sobre
hipertrofia mas também abre novas
possibilidades pro design de program de
Treinamento imagina-se que no futuro
protocolos híbridos combinando treino de
resistência treino de musculação
tradicional com alongamento intenso
poderiam oferecer talvez benefícios
superiores a qualquer abordagem
isolada e a descoberto também levanta
questões interessantes sobre a evolução
da musculatura humana e a sua capacidade
de adaptar-se a diferentes tipos de
estresse
mecânico por será então que os nossos
músculos respondem ao alongamento dessa
maneira com hipertrofia né Que vantagens
evolutivas isso poderia ter
proporcionado são as perguntas
eu achei isso aqui essa parte final a
mais
interessante esse estudo de proteínas é
seguro não querem vender
mais me parece que o estudo não teve
viés viu viu Maria
Elena a caseina eu sou desconfiada dela
tá eu não utilizaria a caseína eu
utilizaria o e Protein ou proteínas
vegetais ou colágeno tá
mas fora isso eu acho que esse estudo
não é tendencioso
não esses fisiculturistas que você
mencionou tomam casina antes de dormir
sim tomam antes de dormir iso é uma
prática comum entre fisicoculturistas é
a casina é um suplemento extraído do
leite
vaca não o cru que eu comentei Eliseu é
que tinha gente consumia cru e tinha
gente consumia usando o azeite para
cozinhar tá agora consuma sim o azeite
de oliva extra virgem aí você vai falar
de marca o azeite Herdade do esporão
extravirgem é cru não o
azeite cru nessa circunstância que eu
acabei de falar todo o azeite que não é
refinado é cru
tá então só se você colocar ele na
panela que ele deixa de ser
cru sim tomar melatonina 3 horas de
dormir segundo Esse estudo é melhor do
que tomar 2 horas
antes Dra Cátia raná recomenda 10 mg
para algumas pessoas pode dar certo tá
mas segundo Esse estudo a dose padrão
entre TRS a 4 mg tá agora tem gente toma
300 mg de melatonina para câncer Ok
então melatonina é muito segura só que
para sono a dose média de 3 A 4 MG 10
pode ser muito para várias pessoas pode
dar
ressaca Boa noite Roberta Tudo
bem então no meu entendimento por tudo
que eu estudei a casina faz mal mas os
fisiculturistas tomam sim tá eu não
conheço suplemento de casina que seja
casina
A2 tá não conheço teria que pesquisar
porque a casina que eles vendem como
suplemento como se fosse o aprin eu acho
que não é casina dois eu nunca vi essa
informação Eliseu é case aí na A1
mesmo bem Pessoal vocês gostaram dos
artigos vamos encerrar por aqui porque
eu tenho que ir lá paraa
academia depois de falar de tanto estudo
de hipertrofia de exercício não sei o
quê eu tô pegando o filme na academia
desde Novembro Dezembro né então eu vou
para lá para não perder aí o meu treino
ok
Sim eu já respondi elizu o as caseínas
de suplemento não são caseína 2 tá Agora
não dá para você ficar tomando leite
casina na do para utilizar isso como se
fosse um uma
caseína para tomar antes de dormir
porque a concentração de caseína não é o
suficiente não sei se eu fui claro que
eu falei aqui uma coisa é suplemento
casina outra coisa é casina que tem no
leite tá o suplemento casina é igual o
aprin é concentrado então só teria que
tomar litros de leite à noite para poder
eh ter casin suficiente né E aí passa
mal né com tanto Leite assim
é vou me alongar sim viu est vou me
alongar eu tô fazendo bastante esteira
também viu Estela pra gente poder correr
ontem eu nem treinei porque eu não tava
com tempo tive uma reunião ontem à noite
então eu eu decidi fazer uma hora de
esteira ao invés de fazer musculação
ontem só fiz
esteira alongar muito na academia tá
bom eu não sei bem como é que foi a
técnica eles utilizaram no estudo lá não
mas 5 minutos de alongamento é coisa
para caramba viu quem se alonga sabe que
ficar mais de 10 segundos já é muito bem
pessoal Muito obrigado aí pela
participação de vocês Nós não vemos na
semana que vem abraço um beijo no
coração